[Music]
do you think we're living in a
simulation yes but it may be
unfalsifiable what do you mean by
unfalsifiable so if the simulation is
designed in such a way that they did
like a formal proof to show that no
information can get in and out and if
their hardware is designed to for the
anything in the simulation to always
keep the hardware in spec it may be
impossible to prove whether we're in a
simulation or not
so they've designed it such there's the
closed system you can't get outside the
system
well maybe it's one of three worlds
we're either in a simulation which can
be exploited we're in a simulation which
not only can't be exploited but like the
same things too about VMs I'm a really
well-designed VM you can't even detect
if you're in a VM or not
that's brilliant so where it's yeah so
the simulation is running in a virtual
machine but now in reality all VMs have
wasted the fact that's the point I mean
is it yeah you've done quite a bit of
hacking yourself and so you should know
that really any complicated system will
have ways in and out so this isn't
necessarily true going forward I spent
my time away from comma I learned [ __ ]
and said dependently typed like it's a
language for writing math proofs and if
you write code that compiles in a
language like that it is correct by
definition the types check its
correctness
so it's possible that the simulation is
written in a language like this in which
case yeah yeah but that can't be
sufficiently expressive a language like
that all weekend it can be yeah okay
what so all right so the simulation
doesn't have to be Turing complete if it
has a scheduled end date looks like it
does actually with entropy and you know
I don't think that a simulation that
results in something as complicated as
in universe would have a formal proof of
correctness
right as we as possible of course we
have no idea how good their tooling is
and we have no idea how complicated the
universe computer really is it may be
quite simple it's just very large right
it's very it's definitely very large but
the fundamental rules might be super
simple yeah
Kondo he's got a life kind of stuff
right so if you could hack
so imagine simulation that is hackable
if you could hack it what would you
change about things like how would you
approach hacking a simulation the reason
I gave that talk I have it by the way
I'm not familiar with the talk he gave I
just read the you talked about escaping
the simulation yeah like that so maybe
you can tell me a little bit about the
theme and the message there too it
wasn't a very practical talk about how
to actually escape a simulation it was
more about a way of restructuring and
us-versus-them narrative if we continue
on the path we're going with technology
I think we're in big trouble
like as a species and not just as a
species but even as me as an individual
member of the species so if we could
change rhetoric to be more like to think
up words like to think about that we're
in a simulation and how we could get out
already we'd be on the right path what
you actually do once you do that while I
assume I would have acquired way more
intelligence in the process of doing
that so I'll just ask that so the the
thinking upwards what kind of ideas what
kind of breakthrough ideas do you think
thinking in that way could inspire and
what did you say upwards upwards into
space are you thinking sort of
exploration in all forms the space
narrative that held for the modernist
generation doesn't hold as well for the
postmodern generation
what's the space narrator we're talking
about the same space the dimensional
space like going a little east like
building like Elon Musk like we're gonna
build rockets we're gonna go to Mars
we're gonna colonize the universe and
the narrative your friend was born in
the Soviet Union you're referring to the
race to space the race to space to
explore okay that was a great
modernist narrative it doesn't seem to
hold the same weight in today's culture
I'm hoping for good postmodern
narratives that replace it so think
let's think so you work a lot with AI so
the eyes one formulation of that
narrative there could be also I don't
know how much you do in VR and they are
yeah that's another eye I know less
about it but every time I play with it
and our research is fascinating the
virtual world are you are you interested
in the virtual world I would like to
move to a virtual reality in terms of
your work no I would like to physically
move there the apartment I can rent in
the cloud is way better than the
apartment I can rent in the real world
well it's all relative isn't it because
others will have very nice apartments
too so you'll be inferior in the virtual
world that's not how I view the world
right I don't view the world I mean it's
a very like like almost zero-sum issue a
to view the world say like my great
apartment isn't great because my
neighbor has one too no my great
apartment is great because like look at
this dishwasher man yeah you just touch
the dish and it's washed right and that
is great in and of itself if I have the
only apartment or if everybody had the
apartment I don't care so you have
fundamental gratitude
you